Come with me to see a movie alone.
I am a mom of two, and I'm very social,
so I rarely ever go out by myself.
But this one night, I decided to go after my kids were asleep.
My husband was home.
I just decided to see this random Liam Neeson movie.
I thought it would be interesting and fun to just relax and watch it.
I got my very own popcorn.
Didn't have to share with anyone.
I also got an ice cream later on.
But I saw the first five or so minutes of this movie,
and I just thought it was kinda boring
and it kinda felt like a dude movie.
So I got up and I went to the theater next to me,
and it was this romantic movie.
It was kind of weird. Weird ending,
but kind of interesting and juicy and just fun and relaxing.
Highly recommend going out by yourself every now and then.